[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Eric green he is an assistant
professor of religious studies at Yale
who specializes in the history of
medieval Chinese Buddhism much of his
recent research has focused on Buddhist
meditation practices including the
history of the transmission of Indian
meditation practices to China the
development of distinctly Chinese forms
of Buddhist meditation and Buddhist
rituals of confession and atonement
today we'll talk with Professor Green
about his forthcoming book Shawn before
Chon meditation repentance and visionary
experience in Chinese Buddhism
welcome professor Greene thank you for
having me so let's begin with your book
give us an overview of it my book is
basically a historical and cultural
study of Buddhist meditation as it came
to be practiced in China in a relatively
medieval or ancient period around the
Year 400 to around the Year 600 so I was
interested in understanding how Buddhist
meditation came to be established in
China and really the history of the
transmission of Buddhism from India
where it begins to China and its
establishment asks really the major sort
of world religion of East Asia
eventually goes on to become the main
religion of Japan Korea Vietnam and all
those other countries so this was a
historical study of a foundational
moment in the history of Buddhism in
East Asia and then also the topic of
meditation which is something that of
course has a lot of cachet and interest
in the modern world as well so I'm
always curious to know how people are
led to study what they do so I am
curious about that and what led you to
write the book well as to sort of
different questions there you know when
I was an undergraduate at college I was
a math major
I taught math in high school well but I
also was studying Chinese language and
also quite interested in Buddhism on a
variety of levels so after college I
kind of did some things and I hung out
with various Buddhist groups in
California and learned more Chinese and
eventually went back to graduate school
so that's the sort of long personal
history of my interest in in this topic
in terms of the actual how you wrote the
book you know I did what most historians
and scholars of religion do you know I
learned to learn to read ancient Chinese
and Sanskrit and read a bunch of things
spent some time in China in Japan doing
research for the book and then you know
closed my door and didn't let anyone
call so let's talk about the research
itself how did you do that yeah I mean
in part it was attempting to discover
sources that people hadn't looked at
before so there are you know the topic
of Buddhist meditation is it quite many
people been interested in before in
China and Japan this word in the title
of my book Chon this is the Chinese
pronunciation of the word Zen in
Japanese which is of course more well
known in English so there's a lot of
things written on this topic but you
know one of the things I discovered in
the course of my research was there was
a large number of documents and also
sort of material cultural remains
paintings and things like that from this
early period that had kind of slipped
through the cracks and that didn't form
part of what eventually becomes a more
mainstream discourse on this later in
Chinese and Japanese history so I had to
uncover those materials and find them
and read them and understand them I
translate them learn enough about the
history of Indian Buddhism to see how
this sort of interaction was happening
in ancient times okay how did the
interaction happen India to China
yeah well Buddhism begins in India sort
of already said and maybe around this
let's say the turn of the Common Era it
comes to China in some form we don't
know very much about the early history
missionaries basically arrived across
the Silk Roads in Central Asia
probably accompanying traders which we
know was a big event that was taking
place at this time across Central Asia
sometime around 200 300 400 Buddhist
communities begin to establish in China
texts scriptures the doctrines of Indian
Buddhism are translated monasteries and
nunneries
form becomes a major part of the Chinese
social fabric of this time and in that
matrix Buddhist practices develop ideas
about Buddhist practices get written
about and thought about in Chinese so of
course you know anyone who studies
periods of time this ancient know many
things about the history that we cannot
we cannot know and reconstruct what
survives to us our archaeological
remains but then also documents and
texts so we learn about the how Buddhist
meditation was thought about what people
thought it was what thought it would do
and then maybe some fragments and
snippets of how it actually takes place
on the ground the kinds of people who
are carrying it out so tell us about
what it was like what were people
thinking of this and how were they
practicing yeah
well I just you know parenthetically one
of the reasons that I was quite
interested in this topic is because as I
said Buddhist meditation is something
which is now sort of well known in
modern Western culture we hear about
meditation practices Buddhism but also
in a kind of more generic spiritual way
spiritual way and then also and maybe we
can say like a mental health way the
well in this industry even here at Yale
we have you know I didn't take my class
they often come and tell me oh yeah you
know there's some group that the sports
team sets up to help people meditate to
get calm before their game and things
like that so we have a certain sense of
meditation as this quite neutral
practice not connected with any specific
beliefs leading to a psychological
mental health in a sense that we can
understand now certainly I it's you know
in ancient China and even in China and
Japan today it is often quite different
from that so a lot of the material I
looked at had to do with traditional
Buddhist meditation practices focusing
on things like the impurity of the body
techniques for reading oneself of sexual
desire or attachment or interest in in
the world things which actually and a
modern perspective might look downright
antisocial in a certain way but this was
really you know what what many Buddhists
have even most Buddhists were interested
in using meditation for and you know in
terms of the people who are practicing
if this is another
area where Buddhist meditation in its
more traditional sense looks kind of
different from this thing which has now
become part of our world and that is
that meditation was was not something
that everyone could do it was practiced
by monks and nuns and not even by uh
monks and nuns by a very small
percentage of Buddhists in medieval
China it was it was a truly sort of not
esoteric but advanced or even hardcore
practice that was not suitable for
everyone in many of the documents that I
looked at and this is something that got
kind of interested in for a while we
find not only that of course meditation
can make you enlightened and turn you
into a Buddha or a saint or things like
that but they could also hurt you harm
your body lead you to sort of insanity
basically but also various kinds of
bodily illness so there was a I have a
line in one of my articles where I say
it was thought of sa a high-risk
high-reward activity I think and this is
this is something which i think is
probably pretty different from how
meditation at least is discussed in most
forms of sort of popular culture
although there is actually not so far
from here at Brown University there's
this psychologist will be Britton who is
doing a study precisely of the negative
effects of meditation that have been not
often talked about but there are even in
contemporary settings there are many
documented cases of people having
adverse reactions so some of the stuff
that I've done connects with those
things but it's still a sort of minority
tradition okay so I am very curious what
the downside of meditation could be well
you know if you're interested in the
sort of you know contemporary reporting
on possible negative effects of
meditation again as I said there are a
few people who are looking at that in
the modern world in you know the ancient
context that I study it's of course hard
to know precisely what was happening in
the ground but from a cultural
historical point of view the interesting
thing what I found interesting was the
way that you know it was not
conceptualized or talked about in a sort
of anodyne this is a universally good
sort of thing that anyone on the street
could just sort of pick up and use to
make their life better or be happier or
kamar in the way that maybe it's been
sort of psychologize for us and in the
modern world this was a this was a
powerful religious technology that had a
lot of potential for doing really
amazing things
but was also needed to be maybe
controlled right not something you could
just assign to everyone and have them do
it because of course it could put you in
contact with divine powers in many of
the texts I look at we have discussions
of you know meditation will lead to
meeting Buddha's and other gods who live
another world and conveying powers to
you things like that this was this is
powerful stuff that you don't just want
anyone to to have access to so what was
the meditation process actually like did
you get any insight as to how they were
practicing back then specifically yeah
well you know certainly we have a lot of
sources which give us kind of techniques
of meditation but the thing that I you
know even more so than the techniques of
meditation what I became very interested
in was the question of you know the
results of meditation and then how that
sort of interacted with the social world
so when people became known as masters
of meditation or adepts skilled the
meditation what then were they able to
do of course become famous Buddhists who
were patronized by by rulers and
emperors but then also this question of
you know who who got to decide when you
had succeeded in it again this is
another one of these things that I think
we often don't talk about we sort of you
know maybe a mindfulness technique is
given to someone you say well you know
you think about your body and you should
have calm your mind and then what you'll
like feel better or something you'll be
less stressed out but and that you know
if you don't think meditation leads to
anything more than that that's maybe
enough but in a traditional Chinese
context you know being a master of
meditation would mean that you were now
someone who could give authoritative
advice to say an emperor or something
like that so it's really important to
know who who that was so many of the the
manuals that I look through they
describe this they say well you know you
if you do this certain practice you'll
have this kind of vision and then you
can know that you've succeeded but if
you're there's other kind of vision or
maybe these sort of negative effects
that I was talking about this is a bad
thing so there was a lot of concern over
regulating the success or failure of
these practices and discerning who was
authorized so who did determine those
things and and
tell us about some of the visions that
were good ones and some where that were
bad one yeah well you know the the
question of who
clerical authorities is probably the
simplest way to say you know who did but
of course which of those which among
them are the ones that get selected to
do that this this is one of these sort
of on the ground soso sociological
questions that it's pretty difficult to
answer come from a historical point of
view but we have some indications we
have stories of you know given
individuals who they're kind of slightly
mythologized biography are said to have
reached some great meditative attainment
and then were appointed to be the head
of some monastery or nunnery we have
paintings of meditation masters who are
depicted with meditating and having
certain visions and levitating - is that
a yeah levitating that's one of the
powers that is described in many sources
not so much in okay in in in China that
I ever encountered being able to sort of
tell the future that's a that's a common
one but also you know other kinds of
magic powers you know be this is a
connection which is which in some places
in the modern world and modern West
people do talk about that as well
although it's may be somewhat segregated
from the more secular versions of
meditation when I was a kid I remember I
can think back to some of my forms of
media that I consumed watching films
like Star Wars The Karate Kid there's a
certain sort of mysticism associated
with meditation even in its modern
Western forms they're really promising
of this kind of power that you might get
and this is this is very sometimes it's
presented as a kind of corruption of the
Buddha's true teaching which is not
about magical powers but I more
accurately historically this this goes
way back in Buddhism this has always
been sort of promised that you would
have the potential to gain this kind of
mastery over both yourself but then the
physical world as well right and were
there any critics of the practice during
this time that you came across I'm
curious because it does seem when I'm
you want any small population can drill
something there's always another force
that has some kind of criticism of it
well I think so in the context of China
which is the sort of place that I've
been looking most at you do have
criticisms of Buddhism as a whole so
even though as I said Buddhism becomes a
kind of major religious force in East
Asia
there are many critics in China who
basically say this is a foreign religion
we trying to do people shouldn't have
anything to do with this in the case of
maybe say within Buddhism and sort of
think what you were asking what's
interesting actually is that we have you
know criticisms of whether a given
person is really should be authorised
has reached this level of attainment or
something like that but not criticisms
of the general principle and this is I
think actually quite traditional when
you look at the way that many religions
operate in traditional context which is
there there's definitely doubt and
contestation about whether any given
person has done this correctly but not
about the principles of the system as a
whole so this this this kind of modern
world we live in in which you know your
religious belief is one option among
many you can either believe in these
things or not and you have to sort of
defend them in the public sphere by
arguing against someone who doesn't that
sort of wholesale doubting is is less
common certainly in China in case of
Buddhism so that there were people who
had these powers no one really whether
you who claimed to were or not that's
and let's get back to the visions
describe some of the visions that people
would say they had oh well yeah the
vision in the many of the this was one
of the reason I became kind of
interested in this particular collection
of documents that I ended up focusing on
for in writing the book is because they
they are really quite incredibly
elaborate as I said before you know
visions of various divinities or Buddhas
but then also connected with certain
specific forms of meditation so I
mentioned these meditations on the
impurity of the body for example this is
a quite traditional Buddhist practice
connected with the idea of getting rid
of a sexual desire but then also sort of
becoming separated from your sense of
self or something like that so there is
a that's a that was one area where you
have an enormous range of you know
visions of the inside of your body of
the organs kind of rotting of yourself
turning into a skeleton of sort of
fields of dead bodies in front of you
everyone you're looking at turning into
a dead body so this is this is the kind
of visions that would often be
intentionally cultivated really within
these things
there were also you know many
examples where the line between a good
vision and a bad vision looks from the
outside rather small so there's one one
particular text I'm thinking of now
where you know they list the practices
and then say well you know if you have a
vision of a of a white dog walking into
your meditation room that's a good sign
but if you have a vision of a camel
that's a bad sign mm-hm and they're you
know it's it's it's it's not so easy for
us to tell why one is good or not well
and it's also interesting because there
to me it starts to cross a line to
mysticism or the occult sort of yeah I'm
like fortune-telling in a way yeah and I
need luck bad luck right and and this is
you know this is actually one of them uh
sort of more kind of within the field
point of view this is one of the things
that I was trying to do in my book which
is to approach the study of meditation
from a perspective that would allow us
to connect it to all of these other
domains Buddhism religious activities so
there's often a perspective and this is
something that in the modern world is
often articulated very strongly that oh
you know meditation is this very sort of
rarefied part of Buddhism and in
practice as I said is a rarefied part of
Buddhism this is not something
traditionally that most Buddhists would
be able to do but idea that it was sort
of intellectually rarefied that yes
there was a whole world of kind of
medieval religion in which people
believed and as you say sort of fortune
tellers and gods and things like that
there was a sort of cadre of you know
intellectual Buddhists who were doing
something similar to us and I think
that's not true and I and I one of the
things I wanted to do in the book I
tried to do is to show the ways that
even when you look at how meditation and
his fruits are being discussed by the
most intellectual strata of Buddhists
they connect it to all the domains so
they they were interested in in
attaining success in meditation to be
able to predict the future to be able to
communicate with the gods even if they
thought there their techniques were
superior to those say that would be sort
of practiced by fortune tellers on the
streets of you know the capital of
people China it was the same kind of
activity and they were still hoping for
the same kinds of say visions or dreams
for confirming their success that you
would find in many different parts of
both Buddhism but also other forms of
did you look at India and what was going
on and how they were practicing Buddhism
there during the same period that they
were in China and are there similarities
dissimilarities talk about that a little
bit yes that's a very large question of
course one of the one of the arguments I
do make in the book is that the
collection of these medieval Chinese
sources for thinking about Buddhist
meditation they're important from the
perspective of China but they're also
important from the perspective of kind
of a broader trans Asian history of
Buddhism so the the material that
survives for the study of Indian
Buddhism we have sort of texts and
sermons attributed to the Buddha himself
and then we have a lot much later of
material there is actually this large
kind of maybe 400 year window in the
middle where there aren't a lot of
sources to study Indian Buddhism so the
the meditation texts that I examine in
my book
many of them were translated from Indian
languages Sanskrit really kind of
medieval other forms of Indian languages
at this time and some were composed in
China so they I think there is their
differences and their particularity is
to the Chinese situation but there's
also a way in which China because of the
tendency of texts to get preserved
they're better than they do in India
where it's actually there's material
reasons for this too because it's very
hot and wet texts are manuscripts from
the medieval times are much rarer in
China you have you have many more this
actually gives us a window onto Indian
Buddhism as well and many of the things
that I were just discussing I think this
this is true of Indian Buddhist
meditation at this time as well so one
of the things I did want to sort of
argue in the book is that this is not a
kind of corruption of Buddhism which is
often how these things get presented
that you have a sort of early pure
tradition of rational meditation not
influenced by all this fortune-telling
stuff and then later you know ask people
stop understanding it or to appeal to
the masses of people or something like
that these things so I do want to argue
and I
do argue in the book that that's that's
not really a correct understanding this
is and through this material in China
from the fourth and fifth century we can
really see that across China and in
Central Asia and then in India as well
even if the view into India is a little
bit murkier because of the long distance
and the relatively fewer direct sources
so ultimately what do you conclude in
your book and what would you like
readers to take away from it yeah well I
I think the main thing that I want
readers to take away from it is I mean
on the one hand there is a specific
question about the history of annotation
in in China in East Asia we have the
forms or this tradition really a sub
sect of East Asian Buddhism Zen it's
quite well known that does have an
approach which maybe looks a little more
familiar to us
emphasizing meditation that's a very
sort of rational abstract procedure so
on the one hand you know specifically to
Buddhism in East Asia to to take away
from it that there's a much richer
tradition there of meditation that
interacts with all these other aspects
of society the religion that we were
just talking about but then you know
maybe for the for the broader reader you
know to know something about the history
of this this thing Buddhist meditation
or mindfulness however you want to call
it now that that that we encounter
around us in many people in modern West
in America we'll find this at various
points you know and to know that how
it's gotten to us is a little bit more
complicated right this isn't just
something that you know some kind of
gift of the Buddhists to the modern
world that we can just take and do what
we want that there was I've been a
selectively gathering in this and
there's some history to that and you
know there are that's maybe something
that people and then it's something that
many scholars have sort of looked at and
said well you know this is this has
taken place within the matrix of
colonialism in the 19th century the
Orientalism and all sorts of distortions
although I think that word is maybe not
the best one but have occurred to create
these sort of modern mindfulness that is
now just a sort of a therapy you can
apply within your you know general
practice of wellness or whatever and
which is now not to say that people
shouldn't be doing that because of
course who who would I be to say that
you shouldn't you know use mindfulness
to you know feel better about
yourself or whatever but there is a way
in which studying the past and seeing a
very different version of something I
can you know challenge the fixed nature
of some of these things that we
encounter and then you know to make us
see that oh maybe you know this isn't
the only way of being in the world there
is a possibility of change and there has
been change in the past that's that's a
sort of general defense of the humanity
is more than anything else but hopefully
something in my book will do that as
well okay fascinating so what are next
steps for you well now so I this
Buddhist meditation topic I've been
working on for a long time and now I'm
starting a new project associated with
the studying the history of translation
in Indian Chinese Buddhism so as I said
before the process of the transmission
of Buddhism from India to China was
accompanied among other things by the
translation of a large number of Indian
Buddhist scriptures this really from a
world historical point of view is
probably almost certainly one of the
largest if not the largest sustained
translation projects in the pre-modern
world the volume of material translated
the distance that had to be negotiated
in terms of the difference between
Indian languages and Chinese the
conceptual differences and this went on
for many hundreds of years and it forms
the basis of the Buddhist Canon in East
Asia but but the process of this
translation the strategies that were
adopted by translators the difficulties
they encountered so I'm doing a project
now associated with the translation that
took place really in the first two or
three hundred years of this process
where the language is often quite
different from what we find in later
literature in China it's quite harder to
understand but you can really see the
the early Chinese interpreters of Indian
Buddhism struggling to make sense of
what at the time was a very very new and
different religion but also a sort of
philosophy and this this will be this is
a something I've long been interested in
and of course it's connected to any
aspect of studying Buddhism in East Asia
but now to focus specifically on this
problem of translation how that took
place and the issues that all right well
we will look forward to hearing more
from you then thank you yes thank you
for being here and sharing your work
with us for more information about
Professor Green and his
research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you